we are please be upstanding to receive
the Chairman the Germans put Chaplin and
the managing director my institution mr.
Richard dolls who say prayers words from
Scripture say this there are time for
everything and a season for every
activity under heaven
the time to be born and a time to die a
time to plant and a time to uproot the
time to kill and a time to heal a time
to tear down and a time to build a time
to weep and a time to laugh a time to
mourn and a time to dance a time to
scatter stones and a time to gather them
a time to embrace and a time to refrain
a time to search and a time to give up
the time to keep and a time to throw
away the time to tear and a time to mend
I'm trying to be silent and it's fine to
speak the time to love and a time to
hate a times of war and a time for peace
is evening we had time together as
counselors you had time to voice your
concerns your issues all under the
hearing of God a moment of prayer our
God we come into your presence
recognizing that you are here we ask
that all wisdom and understanding will
be spoken and shared it grants you
access to this place and may we know
your presence be with each and every one
of the counselors here as they conduct
themselves
may they look to the betterment of the
community in which they serve and that
the outcome will be of honour and glory
amen
thank you you made a stay or I'll go as
you wish thank you
please be seated
item one on the agenda apologies for
absence
apologies received in the office are
councillor I a new counselor toby
mountains counsel stanley and councillor
rotom's are there any others thank you
madam chairman I can't learn sandy left
II can't make it thank you
capital of his nation
thank you very much for that item 3 I'm
sorry item 2 going ahead of myself again
minutes of the annual meeting held on
16th of May 2017 and of the
extraordinary meetings held on the 31st
of May 2017 and the 22nd of June 2017 do
we agree those now we're on item 3 to
receive declarations of interest
counselor each declare a non-pecuniary
non pecuniary interest in item 8 8 3 by
virtue of being a member of ready Town
Council working party and regards to the
toilets public toilets thank you thank
you Anne non non peculiar interest as a
member of ready time council Thank You
council mr. Shaw
council alum this is lovely Thank You
chairman and don't be Curie in cases - 7
XR 8.1 112 and also as an overrated Town
Council
Thank You councillor staring
non-pecuniary interest chairman in
relation to item 8 point 3 although I
did not participate in any of the
discussions I am a member of Rayleigh
town council and aware of what has been
going on there
Thank You counsel well thank you madam
chairman non-secure new interest please
in item 8 point 3 as a town councillor
and I sit on a subcommittee for public
convenience thank you
thank you madam chairman on kikuna
interest in item 8 3 by virtue of being
a member of resi town council and a
member of the Working Committee of the
Crown Hill toilets thank you before we
carry on can I please ask members I'm
sorry
two more 1012 as a member of sanctuary
Samantha thank you castor Williams
was there anybody else chairman if it's
found necessary to declaring war
counselor as an interest I'll declare
that on eight point one as a ward
councillor Lodge no others right can I
please ask members of the public to
refrain from disturbing the meeting and
remind you that counselors have been
democratically elected to make decisions
at the district council if you continue
to disturb the meeting it will be
impossible for councillors to hear all
the points that are going to be made and
I will have to ask members of the public
to leave the council chambers if they
continue to disrupt the meeting so
please so if you could please sorry
counselor black thank you middle done
little bit surprised I'm not familiar
with what members declaring
non-pecuniary interested was more
councillors I would have four either you
live close enough if you live close
enough you have a pecuniary interests
other wisest of all councillor I'm not
familiar with members declaring in that
way
but that is a matter for individual
councillors to declare their own
interest but possibly with advice from
chairman and law it's it's given the
items on the agenda and it was reading
relation to the public conveniences and
the front viscosity in the participation
involved the consultation and in the
interest of transparency you can declare
nor the community interest but is all my
advice members should commence wish to
patient thank you item for item for
announcements from the chairman leader
ahead of paid service I would just like
to say just a few words that since May
since becoming chairman IV honor and
privilege to represent our Council to
many events I won't list all of them
because there have been quite a number
they've been very varied from schools to
fairs concerts for schools open gardens
scouts so just to let you know that I am
getting around every part of our
district and will continue to do so and
it's been very enjoyable meeting a lot
of the residents and seeing what is
going on in our district thank you
right we're now on to item five public
questions and member questions on notice
we have received public questions from
mr. Richard Lambourn
so here
we go right in November to 2016 the
planning department and this is a
question for Ian Ward the planning
department in yourself issued several
press releases about returning into
properties back into the housing stock
owners were to be contacted they were to
be offered up to a thousand pounds and
further to that each property was to be
visited you personally were quoted in
the local press stating that this will
be a significant step in increasingly
affordable housing available to the
people on our DC's housing list can you
confirm how many properties were visited
how many responses did you get how many
properties will actually return to the
housing stock and at what cost
finally to those houses that were empty
the many years how many have been are
planned to be compulsory purchased by
planning of course went to go thank you
cancer ward thank you as a response well
just the answers will be complete so
I'll read them slowly the planning
enforcement service visited in the
region of a hundred properties using the
resources of two students we had through
the summer from anglia ruskin they were
in excess of 60 responses by email and
approximately a further 20 by letter
five long-term empty properties I empty
for at least six months have been
returned to use of these one is now
private rented and following
negotiations with the owner has been
nominated to the housing option
service for their exclusive use this is
a very good outcome and has increased
our supply of affordable accommodation
for those residents most in need for our
owner-occupied private housing continues
to be the eyes and ears of our housing
options service for all empty homes
grant inquiries and where relevant will
talk to property owners about nomination
partnerships in addition there are six
further cases currently in progress and
the total spend to date on empty homes
grant totals 4,000 pounds finally in
terms of those properties that have been
empty for many years none have been or
are planned to be compulsively purchased
thank you madam chairman Thank You mr.
lamborne you may ask one supplementary
question which is related to your
question or to the answer and that can
take one minute so well there is one
property
I didn't understand before you not vote
according to Constitution should stand
you should have stood before do want to
read my question again
no thank you counsel well there is one
property in our Ward in Woodland Avenue
number five woodlands Avenue which has
been empty for 30 years is that part of
this program
come to the Lord thank you yeah right
thank you let's the end of that item we
will then go on to item six business
from the last council meeting there is
none item seven to note the minutes of
executive and committee meetings held
between the period of the 18th of April
to the 11th of July as listed is that
noted members item eight to consider any
report from the executive and committees
to Council I think the first one is
councillor Burton thank you madam chair
members will have seen that the attached
report with recommendations put forward
by the review committee members will
know that this particular item has been
discussed at length
following considerable interest from the
public as chairman the review committee
I believe it was both important and
useful to both members of the committee
and to officers to fully understand the
residents concerns and to be aware of
the facts surrounding the change of use
of Francisco si Lodge and Clarence Road
flats I hope that members have had the
chance to fully read the report and
recognize that in my opinion the notes
of the committee has included which are
detailed in point two point three of the
report are equally as important as the
recommendations also put forward by the
committee
I hope the members will agree the
recommendations contained within the
report this evening Thank You councillor
Webb
thank you madam chairman I welcome the
recommendations from review and would
like to thank them all the hard work
that has gone into this as a council we
do have a tremendous opportunity to
support those in our district who need
support during difficult circumstances
and to house them in temporary
accommodations within our districts the
fact that homeless households will be in
one location allows support where needed
to be provided easily
I recognize the recommendation that
review is made and would like to move a
motion that I'm happy with these three
recommendations thank you madam chair do
we have a second I had already put my
hand up well I didn't see who was first
it give to you on a second it I can't
general I wish to speak I'm not
interested you know the semantics of who
stated a motion
counselor Gooding thank you to Evan I
just like to second the motion
thank you thank you so we do have a
motion on the floor
councillor Matt mr. Mason as a member of
the views meeting I'm supporting the
recommendation was it has been discussed
with very great lengths over two hours
that sent review committee probably
longer and then again at the following
review committee since then I'd like to
thank Louisa most particularly because
residents have been sending questions to
to members all members of the council
and I've been sending them on to Louisa
and she very kindly answered them all in
depth and responded to additional
questions and these are being passed
back to residents so I'm very pleased
and that the council supported me and
other members in this respect however I
haven't changed my mind since I suppose
that full council a couple of months ago
and we know that the majority of people
who become homeless
nationally all those single and are not
advertising practice a single mothers
and with children and I really regret
that councils had to send them to
far-flung areas such as pink harlot hit
Lee yet alone South in and I welcome the
opportunity to bring them back into the
district
I would have liked they're serving other
options available I would have liked
there to be a great number of other
options available at the time when this
was put forward by the council to two
century but it isn't the case and I
think we need to ensure that we do keep
our residents in our district close to
their their friends and relatives and
their children their schools and frame
so I commend the promotions and it's
completely thank you very much skin
Thank You councillor Mason caps the
black yes thank you madam chairman yeah
I mean but probably the key factors here
are the last however look obviously last
sentence on page eight point one point
one he was not into what's the district
councillors who did not have a right to
instruct century to do anything and also
on page eight point one two it was noted
that sanctuary owned France is pretty
lodged and that the council had the
opportunity to assist for homeless
residents of the district but improve
processes were needed it's a great pity
Madame showing in my opinion but social
housing still isn't is no longer under
local Democratic control we could have
had different outcomes better outcomes
but government ideology over the last
ten years or more they sent us down this
road and I think maybe the country as a
whole will realize that some of that's
been a mistake pretty soon so I see the
recommendations here I seeing under the
third recommendation but we have the
power to enforce the retention of
nomination rights for at least five
years I would have liked to have seen
some kind of warden installed fcl
because I think
helped situation you know even for first
couple of years I'm not particularly
impressed at the moment mother by
sanctuary deal with cases of nuisance
for their tenants caused by people
outside this is the other people with
residents are concerned here about
nuisance from tenants but I've been
concerned about nuisance from outsiders
on tenants and I'm not politically
impressed in the way century of dirt
with that so I would have liked to have
seen a warden installed there to help
the thirsty over to at least I don't see
it happening sadly just unfortunately
now we are fairly powerless in this
respect thank you
thinking councillor Ward thank him madam
chairman is the first opportunity I've
really had an opportunity to speak as
well councillor in regards to Francisco
tea I do welcome councillor Mason's
words and his sentiments in regards to
the whole situation of course other
solutions would have been preferable
there are many things that would have
been preferable but we were faced with a
very serious situation that we had to
deal with and as it stands this was the
only way in which we could truly deal
with it I can understand what other
members and their and their thoughts are
on this but I believe as we have said in
regards to how we're going to deal with
Francisco tea is we will be looking and
monitoring I believe in the messages
that have gone out from our assistant
director there is a mas who has worked
tirelessly in ensuring that we get the
full nomination rights this was
something that was very very important
we will be putting our own vote into
France is kotti our own folk who are at
this moment in bed and breakfast and we
need to really look at that seriously we
have a moral duty but not
that we have a fiscal duty to everybody
we have to make sure that what we are
doing is the right thing and as I say I
can take on board exactly what councilor
black has said I take on board what
councillor Mason has said and I thank
you for your words because you know they
are a strong point that we need to be
together to understand that homelessness
nationwide is a massive massive problem
that has to be dealt with and it's not
an easy subject it's not an easy problem
to solve but we have to go about the
best way of solving it so thank you very
much for this opportunity
madam Speaker to speak on it now thank
you cancer cut man being said I'm really
pleased that this has come through 2's
echo their words of counsel award I
think it's a real exceptional
opportunity for us to grasp this and the
people I'm most peaceful are those
people who are most unfortunate god
forbid that any of us hear through
circumstances not of their own making
ever find themselves in a homeless
situation I'd like to think that they
have a council that connecting the best
interests of the both them and their
families going forward we also now have
a similar property in Rockford which
we're taking forward as well and I think
this is a much much better solution than
dispersing those people with the
relative disruption to things like
schooling and other things jobs etc for
those people who are in this situation
so I welcome them chairman and I will
obviously support the recommendations
thank you thank you
and finally council Hook why thank you
madam chairman
many year many weeks ago in this whole
process started there's probably a
number of people who thought that this
process of the review committee looking
at this in detail might have been a
waste of time I think what has happened
since as showed that that it hasn't
because it is allowed members to be much
more informed about the whole process
and also the publicly read great
concerns there has been information
which has come out through this process
that we weren't aware of before and
we've been able to make appropriate
recommendations which is in part of part
of this report and it also shows the
limitations on the council in relation
to this whole episode but ultimately I
back the recommendations in the report
thank you thank you
right members we have a motion on the
table for the recommendations is that
agreed thank you
8.2 game count of the Burton thank you
madam chair this is one of three reports
on treasury management that the review
committee sees and considers on an
annual basis again our trust members
would have had the chance to review this
report and consider the recommendations
put forward by the review committee and
we'll be happy to release this evening
if any members have any questions or
queries I'm sure that our section 1 5
104 said will be only too happy to try
and answer them thank you
thank you councillor Smith
sorry happy to note the report be noted
is that great members next item is 8.3 I
believe caps the scepter take a chair
and firstly may have apologize for my
voice I've been struggling with it
sometime I never like to apologize to
other councillors in event of the public
as the chair of the investment board
Huntress I'm pleased to present this
report I firstly I would like to
congratulate the officers and their
teams alongside with the portfolio hope
for all the hard work over the over the
last couple years that I've now gone
gone into doing this and I know there's
been a lot of work behind the scenes
indeed there are still talks going on
with to further parishes parishes and
town council have also worked hard on
this joint project and I like to thank
them for their support and this matter
without their help it would not be
impossible the report takes forward the
decision made by previous full council
to set out the business case there by
parish and town councils are given the
opportunity to take the responsibility
of running public conveyances for
ten-year period
Michael Dubois it's very good let me ask
the phrase public no talking while we
control yes click please members of
public we are trying to conduct business
here if you could please be quiet
cherrylle give it a moment and wait for
people to leave Thank You councillor
sorry about that when you continue
counselor steps let's check I repeat
this the last paragraph the report takes
for the decision made a previous fall
Council to set out the business case
whereby parish Town Council's are given
the opportunity to take full take the
responsibility of running public
conveyances for a 10-year period
required budget 330,000 will give a
return of an on investment of
approximately 15% and payback period of
four years it should be low you viewed
as low-risk project and secured an
annual saving fifty thousand to Rockford
Council
I would like to bring bringing it to the
attention of members the council had
previously agreed that disposing closure
of public loose toilets should be
achieved by 2 April 2008 therefore
should we fail to agree this transfer of
the toilets facilities to a parish or
town council as set out in this paper
they will probably close so as noting
the vote against the report will be a
vote for closure for therefore move the
council accepts the report the
recommendation on the Investment Board
is written on page eight point three
point two the last paragraph and I also
call for a recorded vote you will need a
seconder thank you
I would invite um Wellington to do the
recorded vote please I'm sorry I think
counselor Eve wanted to speak sorry a
new toilets in the areas that we
represent members are we aware that
we're working on the members of vitally
group of this project have been
reasonably understanding in the way that
is proceeding however having viewed what
has been presented to us tonight end to
the investment board I have a number of
concerns especially there are some
factual errors in the report I believe
that the contract although stated as
being with sitter he's actually sewage
is that I've fully back to the right
thank you
members are advised in the original
report presented at all council on the
thirty determine that we could not
cherry-pick the toilets we were to oak
could open or close it was case of all
or nothing however members will note
that the report states on page eight
thirty six that pop clean toilets will
be singled out stay open as it quotes
serves a specific amenity function one
has to wonder how the other toilets
would be described if they don't serve a
quote specific amenity function having
had questions regarding the contract and
the advice given to full council that we
could not allow one to stay open and the
others to close I asked to view the
contract the council hands with sewers
having used that contract I can report
to members that the opposite is actually
true in that we can actually bury the
contract however we deem necessary and
it is it does not carry any financial
penalty
I emailed a request to member services
on Thursday last week asking for a copy
of the mint the last-minute advisory
group held on 15th of June and recording
of the presentation made to be
investment board on the 11th of July the
purpose of which was to ensure that I
could be accurately informed on the
consideration for the Investment Board
report at least before tonight
reply RC told me that they would not be
available until after full council have
discussed the project what concerns me
most is that I wonder what the actual
motive of the exercise really is the
answer that you'll be given loudly and
clear is that due to budget cuts we have
to make hard decisions and if we don't
take those decisions now we will have no
other option than to close the toilet
without any substitute I would remind
members that when we discuss the issue
back in February that I offered a costed
alternative that would meet the budget
requirements keep the toilets in watch
the district control and avoid the issue
of spending vast amounts of money from
our capital budget and at officer and
member time in exploring direction but
that every time I raised this point it
has been brushed aside this was one of
the reasons why I was asking for the
minutes of the members advisory group
which we don't have
I visited the hotp parish office and in
conversation with the client was told
that he had not been given a time scale
for closure of the aqua toilets that's
what he said which we are now will I
want to challenge the members of the
administration specifically those
members represented in hotly and hotly
and Ashington to consider their position
here tonight I've taken the trouble to
find a lot in the residents because I
represent what the feeling is in Cochran
regarding closure of the public toilets
the overwhelming response has been to
keep them open
under the proposal before us tonight
properly sized toilets will be closed
without any substitute alternative and
due to the current circumstance
there is no start date for that item I
will tall that I'll finish that Thank
You Angelica de cáncer sparing do you
want say something
Thank You chairman mr. hutton myself as
you're all aware were were tasked with
trying to work out a leasing arrangement
with Raley Holdridge and Richard
counsels we have done this we've met
these councils on more than one occasion
over many months we've answered every
question that these councils are
presented to us we've answered least
questions we know that they have Rios
with each other they fully understand
what they are committing themselves to
they fully embrace the opportunity to
take on the responsibility of their own
within their own areas the financial
situations has been approved by a
principal finance officer and our 15.0
sir as being justifiable and a good move
for the District Council with parishes
and the Town Council are fully as I said
fully aware of the financial commitments
and while nobody knows what's going to
go on in the future they understand at
the moment they're not kept that may
change in the future
already as I understand looking for
further third-party relationships to
assist with this and I would suggest
chairman that we move to the vote thank
you very much thank you I hear what you
say that moment is about the word to
people waiting to speak so councillor
black just like to Stauffer the question
please the move of the motion stated
that if this motion is dejected tonight
this would lead to the closure of all
the toilets our last officer advice
please if this motion is rejected
tonight then would the toilets close
into your course
without any further decision of counsel
or what a decision of counsel or of one
or another element of the council have
to be made to close those toilets could
have you asked to that first police
mention thank you right hello the
original report was saying the full
council in December and stated that we
would seek the basically that all public
sites of exception of those are hoppy
Whizzer disposed of I closure and sale
or through transfer of the assets for
long term lease to the relevant town
stroke parish council dispose of these
assets to be completed by April 2018 so
my understanding is that that was all
the recommendation is approved in
December and the member of visor group
which is referred to was to be set up to
sort of oversee is like to ensure that
the closure the impact of the closed was
minimized but nevertheless the closure
has effectively being decided by that
violence to sort of a decision so it's a
term that's all public toilets of the
exception of those that hopefully would
are disposed / closure and sale or
through transfer of the assets upon a
long term lease to the relevant town
stroke parish council disposal of these
assets to be completed by April 2018 it
for delegating decision to the next
point down goes on to prove here which
one's the most relevant for yourself to
say that for interior decorating system
director environmental certainty and
contact consultation the portfolio
holder for environment and portfolio
holder for enterprise to oversee that
the closure and sale of public toilets
as above subject to appropriate public
consultation and headed so that wasn't
consultation member advisory group but
nevertheless closure is very much in the
gist of the portfolio list
yes that's correct yes it would it would
trigger a if you like a further meeting
remember advisory group so I would see
the public consultation thank you
of course the vein not of a selfish ward
members point of view this is great for
my ward because really the downhaul part
of my ward will be paying through their
lady town council tax to water budget
audits but all of residents in who would
use milady towards wouldn't pay nothing
at all so from from very selfish balls
point of view which is great however I
try not to be a selfish small councillor
and I have to look at other palaces
which are facing closure of a toilets
completely and I find that very hard to
accept and very hard to support
apparently being these palaces are like
Voldemort you can't mention my name
tonight but I think they know we're
talking about thank you very thank you
final question coming from Kamsa mr.
Mason
thank you and I wasn't going to speak
actually that as counsel aspecto has
stated that any vote against is a vote
for cloture I feel I have to stand and
clarify my position I voted against the
proposal last time it was raised at full
council I've seen nothing to change my
mind I objected on the grounds of
passing the costs to a non-cat Council
or non-cat councils I don't think that
ethical and I believe we should in this
council be undertaking the highest
standards of ethical behavior and I
don't see exact achill at all and I
don't think the residents will see it as
ethical because when it comes down to it
they won't be paying any less the public
purse would have received no significant
benefit so to claim a 15% yield on the
capital employed I'm afraid a smoke and
mirrors and if you want to put it to the
public I voted for cloture I'll happily
explain why I did and I am pretty sure
they'll understand
my approach to finances so it's not
about foreclosure it's a vote against a
process which transfers costs from one
council to another where the other is
not capped in a in a situation where the
cabinet of this country of this
government has declared austerity
remains that's not the benefits
austerity if you ask me could we make
savings elsewhere and retain this in the
district council yes and to and before
someone else stands up and says I've got
something else to add even though the
debates close I'll say the cabinet
members could give up their special
allowances that would be enough to pay
for it
the Germans clothes would be baked so I
leave it at that
I should be voting against you thank you
right you can go to the boat now players
and it recorded vote
councilor black councillor Burton
Chancellor mrs. butcher canceler Carter
counselor mrs. Kassar counselor Cooper
counselor cut more counselor Dre
counselor Eve's counselor gooding
counselor Griffin counselor Hazelwood
cancel a hook way counselor mr. toy
counselor this is used
cancer Lucas skill counselor mrs lammle
counselor mrs. Mayton counselor John
Mason cancel Emeric counselor Milne
counselor Newport counselor mrs. Rowe
counselor mrs. Shaw counselor Smith
counselor sparing counselor Steptoe
counselor ward councillor Webb can
solicit Western counselor Williams
counselor Wilson
you
you
you
that is carried and k21 411 against the
next item is item 8.4 councillor Burton
I think you're going to do with this one
thank you madam chair and I trust that
members will find this short report put
forward by the review committee to be
fairly self-explanatory and agreeable
the subject matter of this report was
discussed informally it says however the
decision to make it formal bring it
forward to a report to four counts of
receiving was a unanimous cross-party
decision
I trust that members would agree this
evening Thank You councillor Webb thank
you madam chairman I welcome this
recommendation from review on Friday I
attended to save any meeting and Hadley
and heard firsthand dr. health speech
again she mentioned Watford in the her
meeting and how this allowed the
concerns to be brought to a head as
we're able to hear from both sides of
the debate I'm pleased to say that in
this district you played a part in
allowing the Commission's to speak out
and as a conservative group we
specifically involved asked that the
lead any consultant be invited to speak
I would like therefore to ensure that
when representations in the NHS are
invited to speak again that dr. Howard
is also specifically invited if she is
not specifically invited to speak then
she will not be able to attend it is
important to hear both sides from those
at the highest level including senior
clinicians I have heard rumors at the
save any meeting on Friday nights that
the news the prevention of the
downgrading of thousand Amy is imminent
if and when this happens we can be proud
of what should council has played its
part
so I would like to endorse his
recommendation but add to it a motion
that dr. Howard be specifically invited
along as part of this thank you very
much madam German castle buddy Thank You
councillor Mason Thank You Sharon again
you know I wasn't going to speak tonight
so I apologize to all those who fed up
with hearing anything from me and I just
like to remind everyone in the chamber
that the original motion was put it was
it was accepted as cross-party and it is
a cross-party decision to ask this
council to detect the matter at full
council in review so there's no need for
party politics you know to be drawn into
this all those others want to bring it
in they can they've just showing
themselves up you know for you know a
rather pathetic point the question I
would ask is will the success regime
allow dr. Howard to sit on the same
panel as then I hope we do but I've got
some doubts that they will also say when
I was I was away I was enjoying a
holiday win the debate which I didn't
know when it was going to happen would
take place one thing I was disappointed
in is that the council made no motion we
didn't make the motion to say we agreed
or disent didn't agree with the success
regimes proposals so the moment we're
technically sitting on the fence apart
from that my good friend
councilor black who suggested that the
council was more or less against that
was as far as it went
so Jalen when it does come back and I
hope it comes back as a result of a
consultation
I hope success regime if they're going
to continue to go ahead will bring this
will bring this to a public consultation
that we have any bait on the
consultation and at last post councils
are sore members to participate in a
motion against the successive regimes
proposals otherwise our position is not
recorded thank you again
Thank You counsel mr. Mason yes my
understanding was that the when they
came along and presented it wasn't for
us to make a decision at that stage but
we did understand the consultation is
going until it's starting in December
with the public but thank you very much
so we've got councillors okay councillor
cut nor did you want Street okay thank
you
so it's proposed that the council
resolves that the NHS be invited to
attend a future meeting of council to
provide an update on the success regime
prior to the end of the public
consultation period into December 2017
is that agreed thank you
yes with dr. Howard invited that will be
in the recommendations thank you item
nine report on urgent decisions is that
noted members item ten report of the
leader of the work the executive
councilor come home thank you madam
chairman members should have a copy of
this on their desks this is the first
ordinary full council meeting of the
2017-18 municipal year and i would like
to welcome all members masses that my
colleagues and I on the executives have
been dealing with include approving the
air quality action plan for Raley for
submission to the Department of
Environment Food and Rural Affairs
delegating authority to the assistant
director Environmental Services to
implement the regulations and in turn
provide authorization to designating
officers within the council to issue
fixed penalty notices for fly-tipping
noting formal responses to children's
City Council's local plan preferred
options consultation and to the
Department for Communities and Local
Government Housing white paper
consultation accepting the South is
extrinsic housing market assessment
known as SH Mar addendum as part of the
evidence base for the new local plan as
always chairman I would be happy to take
any questions from members in respect to
the work of the executive I'm sure my
executive colleagues will be happy to
contribute where appropriate Thank You
Jimmy Thank You councillor cut not count
the black always glad to keep executive
happy so I've got a question with regard
to be air quality Action Plan
when do we envisage situation improving
that the air quality management area can
be revoked
Thank You counselor the back I'll just
check the documentation to get answers
back to you in a couple of days if
that's okay thank you
I'll copy all members thank you thank
you
any further questions thank you madam
chairman I don't have any knowledge of
jumps and City Council's local plan I
haven't really think about anything
about it could we have some background
information thank you and I through
YouTube and it'd be rather difficult to
go through a local plan in its detail
may I suggest that the member actually
has a look through the minutes and the
papers for the executive engine be
you'll find all the information there
chairman he doesn't please contact me
thank you very much now go on to item 11
motions on notice there are none item 12
sanctuary Housing Association
Development Program with disgruntled
meeting on the 25th of April I was asked
to have a discussion with sanctuary
along with leader of the council
councillor cut more to gain some
understanding of the proposals by
sanctuary in relation to the 363
properties that they were to commit to
by 31st of March 2018 key point I think
from from the report and I've set out
some detailed information around the
delivery of mechanisms for the delivery
of affordable housing that I think the
key to key points to note chairman
relate to the interpretation of the
specific Clause in the
the variation that relates to the 363
properties as I've said in the report
that there is nothing in the DS
variation that restricts the delivery of
the 363 to being all affordable houses
within the government's current
definition of affordable housing the
second point I think I'd bring to
members attention is the progress to
date in relation to the delivery of or
the commitment to the 363 houses and if
you look at paragraph 3.1 of the report
you'll see that to date in terms of
current schemes sanctuary Housing
Association has 206 236 new units are on
the way of which 122 are affordable rent
and 56 shared ownership so that 75 of
that total to date and in the pipeline
as a further 268 Wellings of which 105
are likely to be affordable rent and 55
units of shared ownership so that's the
the findings of the conversation with
with sanctuary Association thank you
chairman thank you cancelled work
much of its housing is either affordable
or a shared ownership and in so doing is
helping us to meet the needs of our
local residents I'm glad that the
council will receive regular update on
this which is welcome and it also enable
us to continue to monitor progress so
I'm pleased to propose a motion that I
support its recommendation and that it
be noted by council Thank You councillor
Ward madam chairman launched a second
match Thank You councillor mr. John
Mason a German this was one that I had
decided to speak on however I wasn't
really prepared to the revelations about
affordable housing that I saw on the
national news this evening various
concerns about the delivery of
affordable home concerns that portable
homes were being swapped for money so it
occurred to me that I really must delve
into this a bit more and certainly on
the public record I want to ask some
questions Tim why did the council
largely forgive the portly deliverable
Piske affordable homes per year over ten
years when it's Housing Register and
those on it we're increasing now members
in review committee through this to my
attention but I haven't had an answer to
that question from anywhere so I'm going
to ask it and then in terms of the sort
of thing I expect when I negotiate in
the green I expect to fix the broad and
important terms of an agreement at the
beginning so I really want to know why
the council didn't fix the numbers and
ten year for delivery at the outset of
the new agreement
I can't understand why and this is
something that this cause review
committee to look at it be there is
another question in it concerns the
members of our sanctuary committee and
I'm going to ask German and you may not
know the answer but I'm sure the members
of the sanctuary committee will know and
they can respond has disagreements and
the development program that's
underlying being discussed by members of
the council at the sanctuary at the
sanctuary committee but that's quite
important the other thing that really
worries me is where we stand at
development committee because here we
are as a council and we're all we're all
here at least we're invited here tonight
and have all agreed previously to this
eighth of June agreement and we're asked
to recognize the effects of it tonight
but if we're on the development
committee always substitutes are we in
some way set it because we've actually
entered an agreement with a developer to
deliver it a number of houses and it's
not in the core strategy these are
windfalls so I'm a bit concerned about
the position we've taken ourselves to
and how we're going to deal with that
I'm sure our legal opposite can do feel
with that so those are the questions Tim
and I'd be obliged for answers painting
German honey on the perhaps I can start
them on the last point in fact I'm not
aware and I need to look through the the
information that I have which I can't
share in detail with with the committee
because of legal restrictions that are
placed on the council by sanctuary
Housing Association in relation to their
negotiations on the
swellings that they're proposing to
deliver but from from memory I think the
majority of the dwellings that have been
delivered through the program that the
sanctuary have developed in the district
are not actually windfalls
they are part of the of the overall
housing delivery so for example in the
same way as CHP Housing Association bids
for in wins the nearly 200 houses that
are part of the 5% provision on whole
Road those are not windfalls those are
part of the policy process that the
council has agreed through its
development plan documents and a
significant portion of the dwellings
that are proposed to be delivered by
sanctuary I think of coming through that
through through that that mechanism
chairman in relation to the other
questions I'm not I'm not sure that
really officers can give an answer to
those questions I think relate to
decisions that were taken by the council
in the pnc discussion in relation to the
DD variation and those are subject to a
council decision
so I would like I recognize I can't
begin tonight but finally asked with the
Lansing director to answering questions
in writing October as exempt so all
members please I don't think his
chairman I'm happy to respond whether
whether I'll be able to provide an
answer to the questions specifically as
when you see my response Thank You
councillor Mason I think what's in the
agenda tonight
is this is a full council request to get
the progress and the update is what was
happening and it is really for noting so
I think all these other questions
perhaps will have to be asked elsewhere
senem um okay what we're sharing a
review committee here this is a response
to review committee report I think those
questions listed are claiming will you
agree to put it on the agenda for review
committee on the next line at Lee
- I think what we have now is the
recommendation for this to be noted
Thank You counselor cat law I did have
camps and mrs. Mason too to speak you
still want to speak thank you very
briefly they could believe it or not I
can't read my husband's writing I don't
think he can read mine but he's covered
most of the points that are going to ask
I want also going to our who made a
decision hat and how it made but it's
not been made clear that perhaps we
could ask that once removed committee
thank you madam chair okay so can we um
note this resolution now sit noted okay
item searching I'm very confused
excuse me for standing on a point of
order but counselor web proposed a
motion that motion was was seconded or
arising check though why have we had a
motion which is just descended into
nothing it's just disappeared
do you agree the motion thank you item
13 returning officer an electoral
registration officer interim arrangement
Angela Moore yes members this is a
further to the departure of Nicholas
canvass is just to ensure business
continuity for elections and to appoint
the roles of returned officer an
electoral registration officer on an
interim basis to your managing director
following the and the third
recommendation that following the
appointment of strategic Director that
those roles be appointed to him for her
thank you is that agreed members
item 14 mr. Scranton house chairman
thank you just three of amendments to
the pay policy set out in this report
the first relates and is explained in
paragraph three point five of the pay
policy which is age policies chairman
I'm looking at a different version of
page fourteen point five so paragraph
three point five so that's relating to
posts evaluated at P or 1820s eighteen
to twenty it's a slight adjustment in
the in the pay scale for grades that
relate to the Joint Council for local
government services the two other
adjustments to the policy are relate to
the appendix at the back of the report
page fourteen point nine chairman those
relate to the establishment of
appropriate pay scales for the strategic
director and for myself chairman thank
you it's that grade
item 15 exclusion of the present public
is that grade